Tennessee woman is suing NASA over some
alleged moon dust
she claims belongs to her Laura Chico
says astronaut Neil Armstrong the first
man to walk on the moon gave her the
vial of moon dust when she was a child
the question now is whether she could be
forced to give it back to NASA
mark Strassmann spoke to chico about the
dust that she says is out of this world
Neil Armstrong's 1969 moonwalk made him
world famous but not to ten-year-old
Laura Murray in 1972 my mom handed me my
dad's business card
and she said turn it over on the back
was autographed
Laura says her father Tom Murray was
friends with the first man on the Moon
through aviation circles she says
Armstrong passed on another gift this
vial that grey stuff inside her parents
told her was dust from the moon did you
even know who Neil Armstrong was I'm not
positive she grew up became Laura Chico
and forgot all about it but five years
ago after her parents died she opened up
her mother's Hope Chest in the Attic my
husband Chris said this is what I said
the moondust
chico learned something else about NASA
the space agency considers all lunar
material government property and has a
history of tracking down any that falls
into private hands but first was her
moon dust even real she contacted lawyer
Christopher McHugh and he had it tested
the story was fascinating almost
unbelievable so we had to verify it the
autograph was authentic
but lab testing on the dust was less
conclusive one test found no evidence to
rule out a lunar origin while another
found it was similar to the average
crust of Earth or perhaps earth dust
mixed with moon dust we've speculated
that this might be a
a sample that was vacuumed off a
spacesuit that was enough for McHugh to
file a pre-emptive lawsuit against NASA
demanding Laura be declared the rightful
owner I didn't want her to be in a
situation where she felt like she had to
hide because if NASA finds out about it
they will come kick your door in a
spokesperson for NASA told us in an
email that the agency was unable to
comment space historian Robert Pearlman
was more talkative great claims required
great evidence and there's not a lot of
great evidence in this case Pearlman
suspects chicos moon dust is Pixy dust
not real
he says Armstrong knew better than to
keep lunar material and never gave it
away to anyone to our knowledge he never
gave moon dust to his sons he never gave
moon dust to his first or second wife he
never gave moon dust to his crewmates I
I've worked with Buzz Aldrin I know he
doesn't have any
but Chico swears her dust and her
stories are real Neil Armstrong never
gave moon dust to his family right why
would he give it to the little girl of
one of his friends I don't know and I
would love to know that what if nASA
says you're essentially keeping stolen
property then they would have to call
their hero a thief and Neil Armstrong
was not a thief we just want to keep our
property a federal court could decide
whether Laura Chico is asking for the
moon for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann Tampa Wow cannot make
this story up now his wife ex-wives
didn't get moondust his right dog did
you get another argument though if he
didn't give it to anyone else
no it's it raises some serious questions
some very serious and we don't even know
if it actually is moon dust really and
it raises serious questions about our
education system if she didn't know who
knew well that is is NASA beating down
people's doors is it
the NASA police yeah I just wanted to
say that I've been tested and they found
no evidence to rule out a lunar orange
TVD will say on top of this story